hey what's up guys mkbhd here now i've
reviewed three really high-end phones in
the past couple of months or so the
samsung galaxy s3 the htc one x and the
samsung galaxy nexus and ever since i've
reviewed the third of those three the
galaxy s3 i get this one very specific
question almost every day and that's
which one should i get so i figured i'd
address all three with this video and
hopefully i'll be able to help you guys
out and make the decision and if you
enjoy it give it a thumbs up so here's
the thing the biggest difference between
these three phones is really the newness
and the price galaxy s3 is the newest of
the bunch it is the most recently
available and it has the highest price
second up would be the htc one x which
has been available for around in about a
month and the oldest of the bunch which
is actually released in november of last
year is the samsung galaxy nexus if
you're stuck between the galaxy s3 and
the htc one x i have to tell you both of
them are very different in terms of
software but they're pretty similar in
terms of hardware internally they're
both quad-core devices the galaxy s3
happens to have two gigs of ram but it
has a sort of a lower quality outside
build they both have an eight megapixel
camera but they're both really really
high end internally and externally so if
you're picking between those two i
actually think you should pick between
you're really picking between sense ui
and touchwiz seriously you should take a
look at the way htc has handled their
updates which is probably not the best
out of them all and the way samsung has
handled their updates with touchwiz
touchwiz is a very very different user
interface than the way htc has handled
since ui and then the nexus comes into
play for those of you with a lower
budget because this phone is a little
bit older but like we said this is
running the latest version of android
because it's a nexus so you're going to
have android 4.1 when you get this guy
out the box now there's a small group of
people that are stuck between the htc
one x and the galaxy nexus and for those
people i always just say go with the
galaxy nexus it's just a sort of a
default for me i have a hard time
recommending the 1x over a lot of things
right now there's a larger group of
people who are stuck between the galaxy
s3 and the htc one x like we said these
are both high-end phones but you're
going to be choosing between touchwiz
and sense ui and lastly there's a group
of people who are saying well should i
get the galaxy s3 which is new or should
i get the older samsung galaxy nexus and
actually save money and there's a valid
point here the galaxy nexus has gone all
the way down to about 350 dollars from
buying it directly from google and the
google play store whereas an unlocked
galaxy s3 is going to cost close to
twice that so here's how you decide if
you want hardware you go with the galaxy
s3 but if you're a real android person
or if you value software you're going to
want to go with the samsung galaxy nexus
it's pretty easy to see that the
hardware of the galaxy nexus it isn't
bad but it is outclassed in pretty much
every way by the galaxy s3 the s3 has a
higher resolution and better quality
camera it has a louder speaker it has a
larger display it has twice the ram it
has twice the cores and a faster clock
speed in the processor it's overall just
every single bit of that hardware is
better and that's why you're going to
want to go with that if you value
hardware if you value software if you're
an android person an android enthusiast
a google enthusiast if you're someone
who likes to get into different roms
modding hacking routing if you're
someone who really values the android
ecosystem and having the latest updates
because you're pretty much promised that
once you get the galaxy nexus that's
google's baby right now android 4.0 on
the galaxy s3 android 4.1 and counting
on the galaxy nexus so if you're a
software person
then you want to go with the galaxy
nexus and last but not least if you're
on a budget you're going to want to go
with the galaxy nexus because that is
just a great phone for the money the
bang for your buck you get out of that
phone it still has a 1.2 gigahertz dual
core processor 1 gig of ram and project
butter which makes it fast i think
you'll be happy with that if you're on a
budget so let me know which one you
would decide to have if you have the
choice in the comment section below and
give a thumbs up on this video if you
enjoyed it what was this thumbs up if
you liked it and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video i'll definitely be
going in a much more in-depth video
comparing some of the hardware i
mentioned in this video stay tuned
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
later
peace
you